this
okay over to you chair thank you thank
you james uh
good afternoon members uh welcome to
this meeting of the planning committee
on wednesday march 2021
um i think we all know a procedure now
how we
run these meetings but i will have to
ask you if you are in attendance so
i will go through your names and if
you're here please say yay
if i don't hear anything from you i know
obviously
they're not here keith coleman cook
council common cook
yes here council robin
yeah here chair uh can answer boyfriend
here jen councillor curry
here chair council dennis i know we have
apologies for
councillor pat moore
council mike garner i'm here to
thank you council david hart
thank you councillor heather keane here
chair
uh councillor paul moore present chair
uh council matthew scott
i'll come back i know sometimes he is a
little bit late because of work
uh councillor george russeski
here chair and councillor scott has said
he's here in the uh
uh messaging just spotted it thank you
for that
uh councillor zesky council right
here chair myself obviously
i'm here uh just go back to council
pat moore
nope right we'll try again
later okay members um if you have
technical difficulties during
the meeting then please contact the
democratic service officers
who are on call who will attempt to
assist you
today's officer is katie her number
is 507.046
and will be on the chat box so if you
have any
problems give it a call i've been asked
all participants to mute their
microphones when you are not speaking
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone in this
listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to
speak to gain permission please
briefly indicate on the chat box to the
right of your screen
and i will then make a note and come
back to you once the person
speaking has finished with everybody
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls
whilst the meet is in progress please
also refrain from checking emails or
conducting any other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions
for the duration of the meeting
also please note that this meeting is
being live streamed
for members of the public and the
following meeting will be has been
recorded so it will be available
on the council's youtube channel
also just to mention offices with us
today
ian livingston planning applications
manager
annabelle hemmins planning officer
james clapson democratic services
katy brewer democratic services and our
legal officer tsuki montague
members requesting to speak under
council procedure
20.1 so if members would make a note
uh councillor bailey on item 4a
upton county primary school councillor
pew
on 4c and 4d
garden cottage duroc councillor
bob bayfoot on 4 f
at 8 percy avenue if there are any other
members
who are listening or asked to be part of
this
meeting to speak under 20.1
could they let me know now please
oh okay
just reading counselor hearts message
here that's fine
um i some agenda one is apologies for
absence i have received uh apologies
from counselor dennis
uh are there any other apologies
thank you councillor scott for letting
us know that you're here
um i think we're missing councillor
pat moore at the moment
agenda item two declarations of interest
i'm aware of one at this stage which is
councillor orban
who is declaring an interest in item 4e
which is margate football club and
councillor organ is aware that he will
have to shut down completely and not be
part of the proceedings are there any
other declarations of interest
no thank you agenda item three
approving in the minutes do members
agree that the minutes of the planning
meeting
held on the 17th of february 2021
be approved but i have a proposal please
thank you very much if members agree
agreed sounds like it thank you very
much
agenda item for a schedule of planning
applications and public speaking
uh once again members i'm sure you know
site visits cannot
take place hopefully as we move
through the opening of various places
that we
will be able to do so if we need to
uh the following items have been
reserved for public speakings
so again if you could make a note of
this items
4a c
4 d 4 e and
4 f
thank you a point of information
i called upon the planning officer mr
livingston to give us an update
information regarding
agenda item 4a upton county primary
school
and gender item for a mob 8
football club yeah
thank you chair um this is just a point
of clarification
on two items as mentioned so on item 4a
upton county primary school the wording
of condition 11
which is the opening hours condition of
the hall has been clarified following
confirmation from the agent
and environmental health and would now
read
that uh the building hereby approved
shall not be used other than between the
hours of 8 a.m
and 4 15 p.m by the school
monday to friday during term time
4 30 p.m and 10 p.m by the community
monday to friday during term time 9 a.m
to 10 p.m monday to friday during the
school holidays
and 8 a.m to 10 a.m 10 p.m
saturdays and bank holidays and 9 a.m
to 8 p.m on sundays
and so the wording of the condition 11
is updated accordingly in the office's
recommendation to planning committee and
i will
see that's going to be one of the issues
that's going to be discussed later
um and on item 4e margate football
ground
the description of development has been
updated to remove
reference to a retail unit which formed
part of the original proposal but was
removed during the course
of the process so now the description
the proposal states
erection of 120 bed hotel and ancillary
facilities including restaurant
newsstands studio spaces cafe club shop
club offices
and car parking the plan
condition which is uh condition two has
also been updated to reflect
updated wording on the ground floor plan
uh on the e stand which will be shown to
members
during presentations later thank you
chair
uh thank you very much ian uh moving on
to agenda item
4a which is upton county primary school
and legend
broadstairs i would ask our legal
officer to read out
notice more public speaking statement in
favor
of the application and the public's need
statement objecting to the application
thank you chair i'll read out the
statement
of objecting from mrs dungar first
she says as the main spokesperson for
the edge end
road residence liaison group it has been
tasked to me to speak on behalf of the
majority of the residents
first we would like to thank councillor
bailey for speaking on our behalf
regarding the
viking academy trusts proposal as per
the
generic document which would allow hires
of the new sports hall to apply for an
extension
beyond the 10 pm curfew and for them to
also apply for
an occasional permission license
allowing alcohol
we look forward to this wording being
removed from the relevant document
which was submitted as part of the vats
planning application
so as to avoid any further
misunderstandings
parking has always been a problem for
residents and there is little on any
documents to explain fully the provision
to be provided
at the very least both the main car park
the area in front of the school
and the overflow car park the area to
the right would need to be available and
accessible
as well as at least two if not all three
gates
to be open this would allow vehicles to
enter and exit without having to try to
pass each other in opposite directions
where it is clearly too narrow to do so
there will be occasions when the sports
hall swimming pool and the field and
possibly even the main building
are in use at the same times with an
increased need for parking capacity
therefore without adequate parking
spaces edge end road will become a car
park
again we therefore request more
information regarding the vats proposals
as to how they plan to accommodate the
inevitable increase
in traffic using the school's facilities
there is a vague mention of the
pedestrian gate from broadstairs road
and the gate from the footpath at the
back of the school to be opened
i can assure you that mrs judd and ms
cobb
will object to having people coming and
going so close to their properties
out of school times partly because of
the issue of noise
but mainly from the concerns of a
serious breach of security
as for the idea of people walking across
the entire
length of the school field from the
footpath along the rear of the school
in bad weather and or at night
this surely cannot be a serious
consideration
we are not against the new sports hall
per se but as neighbors
we feel that we should be awarded more
consideration and given more say
had we been informed and consulted more
at an earlier stage
we would not be having to make these
objections now
we would just remind everyone that this
is predominantly
a residential area i will now read out
the statement in favor from mr curtis
chair of governors at upton junior
school
this application is to replace an
existing sports facility for pupils
which is totally unfit for purpose with
a new one intended primarily for their
use
the school has received a grant of
government funds for this purpose
in accordance with government policy we
shall offer the sports hall as an asset
for use by the wider community
when not in news for the school the
relatively small size of the building
this is not a full-sized sports centre
means that it will only be suitable for
a range of activity
involving limited numbers badminton
groups yoga dance classes etc
the great majority of concerns expressed
by residents appear to stem from
unfortunate misunderstandings of one
of the two documents added to the portal
on december 24
in response to request from the planning
officer following a site visit on
december 9th
for further details of the conditions
for hire to the community
this document is the school's lettings
policy this
this is a generic policy applied to all
buildings in the three schools which
make up the viking academy trust
as such it is a capsule document
designed to cover any eventuality
the fact that the policy mentions hiring
out buildings for social events
at one point mentions alcohol and as
another talks of the possibility of
extending harvey on 10 p.m
on rare occasions coupled with the fact
that the plan
includes a small kitchen has led some
residents to fear that the school
intends to offer the sports hall
as a commercial venue for all sorts of
social occasions
this is not the case the design of the
whole does not lend itself to such
lettings
although we can foresee that there may
be some small demand for sports related
children's parties for pupils in the
early evening and for club presentation
evenings
these would clearly not be regular
occurrences had we wish to offer the
school regularly as a commercial venue
for social gatherings
we would have been aggressively
marketing the school hall which is not
only better suited and equipped for such
purposes
but also has an attendant and far more
expensive kitchen
it is perhaps worth pointing out that
one of the relatively few social
occasions on which the hall has been
hired for social occasions out in the
recent years
is the mayor of broadstairs annual
charity quiz night
concerns about lack of parking seem to
stem from the misapprehension of some
residents
that the sports hall will be let out for
community use while the school is in
session
in fact as the proposed timetable posted
on the planning site makes clear
it will only be available for hire when
the school is not in session
at such times there is ample parking
available on the school
site several thousand pounds have been
spent over the last year in improving
the surface of the car park
and improving signage to deter cars from
exiting the site in the wrong direction
as far as noise is concerned given the
sighting of the proposed building at the
rear of the school building
away from edge end road the fact that
the sports hall component
only has one external door and being
designed for sports
only has limited high level window space
we do not expect this to be a
significant issue
as noted earlier we do not intend to let
the sports hall out
for the sorts of occasions at which loud
music will be played
however as is stated in the school's
lettings policy
we are happy to ensure that noise levels
are kept within parameters laid down by
environmental health
we are also happy for it to be a
planning condition that community use of
the sports hall
should not extend past 10 p.m it is
worth noting that
anxious to avoid being seen as
preempting the granting of planning
permission
the school has not informed parents and
pupils of the proposed development
had it done so we have no doubt that
with over 500 pupils
there would have been several hundred
comments from local residents in support
of the application
thank you chair uh thank you suki
um i'm not sure whether any members or
staff
officers realize i disappeared from the
screen there
not sure what happened um technology but
i've
moved back on thank you uh i called upon
uh counselor
bailey to speak as war counselor please
thank you chair and good evening members
um i think mrs dungars actually
said most of what i was going to say
i've actually facilitated this call-in
on their behalf
i am very positively in favor of this
sports hall
um i think it offers um a great uh
facility for both school children and
for the wider community
um but there is however one thing i do
agree i i i mean i
do know that the um residents have
several
uh different um
concerns but i think most of them are
either surmountable
or or the benefits of these new sports
hall
outweigh them but i do agree with them
on the
fact that i don't think it should be
used for a function
a social function space it is a
residential area
and no matter what the um there seems to
have been a bit of a breakdown
between relations between the academy
trust and the residents and which is
unfortunate
um but they do actually say in their
terms and conditions
uh that uh you know they will allow
um permission for alcoholic drinks if
there is
um an occasional permission license
and uh there are references to allowing
it to be
used as a function um hall um
tdc have unfortunately the um
the response came in after the call-in
and also i think the environmental
health
um things went up on the portal after
the call-in so
um environmental health has stipulated
some conditions which
i would um i would ask members if they
would re
enforce um especially the time curfews
the noise limiters um
and i would also uh ask members to
consider adding a condition that would
preclude
the use of alcohol on that site as it is
a residential area
and i think that's all i've got to say
thank you
thank you councillor bailey um i now
call upon the planning officer who i
believe
is annabelle uh to give the details of
this application
thank you chad just share my screen
uh hopefully members can now see my
screen i can
thank you
and this is the application site
outlined in red
we have edge end road running um
north to south along the right hand side
of the slide
and the footpath that's been mentioned
running to the rear of the site here
the
sports hall that's been referred to is
in this location here so this is the
existing sports hall and the replacement
one would sit in the same location
albeit
it would be slightly larger
so we have an aerial photograph of the
site again we can see edge end road
um this are the main buildings of the
school
the swimming pool building and the
sports hall as existing here
and you can note that the surrounding
and boundaries of the site
are heavily landscaped and there's a
good amount of tree
coverage around the borders of the site
so zooming in on the site we have edge
in road
on the right hand side here we have the
main school complex
the swimming pool building here and the
existing sports wall
and you can see there are free trails
adjacent to the existing sports hall
which are actually proposed to be failed
to accommodate the new sports hall
but i will come back to talk about those
later
um so you have some photographs there's
16 sports hall
so the main school classroom buildings
are on the right hand side of the slide
this is the rear of the existing sports
hall with a decking area here
again the rear of the sports hall and
you can see the school
the school field and this is looking at
the other side of the sports hall the
swimming pool building the sports hall
here
and these are the trees that are
proposed to be failed
and just some quick photographs of the
parking that is available on the site
so we have parking area here with
entrance from edge end road
this is the parking area which is again
from that same entrance
so we've actually looked at the
photographs
of the sports hall as it stands now in
this location
the dotted line is the actual footprint
of the proposed
sports hall and the parking area that
sits
in this location here so this is the
existing site plan
so the main school building classroom
buildings are here
and here we have the end of the swimming
pool
building here this is the existing
sports hall
and these are the three trees that are
actually
proposed to be removed the
application was accompanied by a tree
survey
and none of the trees on site are
protected by virtue of a tree
preservation order or by virtue of being
in a conservation area
the all but one of the trees on site are
identified as being category c
and that is the case of these three
trees here that are to be failed
but their provision has been made and is
secured by condition
for replacement of the free trees
elsewhere within the site
so this is the um proposed
sportszone as noted you can see the
dotted red line here is sort of
the area of where the existing sports
hall is so it is a larger area
and it might be difficult to see but the
canopies of the existing trees
that are to be removed are outlined in
red by dotted lines
so the maximum height of the sports saw
would be 7.9 meters
and then it drops down in the area of
the change rooms and kitchen
area to a height of 3.6 and at its
widest part
is 17.4 meters
and again the width dropped us down to
10 meters
at this smaller element to the rear
so just a series of elevations so we
have the existing south elevation
and as you can see there it is annotated
that's the area that's going to be
demolished
and this is the proposed self elevation
so you can see it
is higher in this part here and then it
drops down
and again this is north elevation you
can see the swimming pool building on
the left hand side now
and this is sports hall with the trees
covering it that would be demolished
and this is the proposed north elevation
so again you can see the higher part of
the proposed sports hall
excuse me and then the lower lower part
which contains the changing rooms in the
kitchen
excuse me this is the existing um rear
elevation
west elevation so this is the one we saw
in the photographs
this is the decking area and again you
can see it is the domed
the dome shape of the building that will
be demolished
this is the post rear elevation so you
can see the smaller part of the
sports hall and then the larger part
which be
the main sort of sports facility this is
the east elevation
and again the proposed east elevation
so these are the proposed floor plans so
as stated this is the main
sort of sports area where games and
activities would take place
these are the changing rooms and a store
associated with it
we have toilets here and a small kitchen
facility
so to summarize the application is for
an updated sports hall
which would be provided for mainly for
school use but providing
as is common for use by the local
community
concerns have been raised about noise
and disturbance and hours of use
um it is noted that there are several
conditions that members would have seen
on the report
they include noise limitations
suggested by environmental health and
also the hours
of opening and use by both the school
and the community
and obviously um as mr livingston has
pointed out
that um condition has been updated but
the latest
opening hours would be till 10 p.m
10 p.m but or and then on a sunday 8 p.m
would be the latest
use for the site concerns have also been
raised about car parking on site
kcc highways have commented on the
application and raised no objection
on the basis that
the existing parking on site is made
available
for community use of the site so the
officer recommendation
is one for approval thank you chair uh
thank you annabelle
um if i may just come in here um
uh councillor bailey has mentioned some
further conditions
uh i have to ask members at this stage
i'm sure you know
they could be looked at at a later date
but at the moment
you are discussing and um
obviously what's in front of you so i
move that the officer's recommendation
is to approve could the vice chair
please second oh second nature
uh thank you counselor coleman cook um i
have a few speakers here
councillor bayford
councillor bayford jill
sorry chair yes that's fine thank you
um yeah i'm very much in favor of this
application
um i think it offers great opportunities
for the school and for um
social social um gatherings afterwards
i don't think there's much chance of a
school
sports hall um
allowing events to get out of hand
i think it would be a great pity for the
government funding
to not to be utilized there are
several conditions which i think allay
many of the fears by the residents
there's just one question i i wonder
whether anabol can tell us
um have you any idea how many cars
could be accommodated in the parking
available
please can you do that annabelle no
unfortunately i
don't as we've seen from
the pictures hopefully you i i can share
them again if need be
yes isn't um demarked so it will depend
how people park as to the number that
can be acquired
the space but we do have the kcc highway
comment that they don't raise objection
as long as the car
probably isn't an issue thank you very
much thank you chair
uh thank you councilman for councillor
alban
thank you chair yes as excuse me
as councillor bayford has just said i
fully support ever what you just said
um i think it'd be a great asset for the
school and for the
community as a whole um the only issue
the only thing that that does concern me
the three mature trees that are being
taken out
um i see their cat category c i mean
i think it would be a benefit
to advise the committee what the
category c
uh tree actually is and that would be on
its
on on their worth and and their uh
impact on the amenity of the area and
can i also be
can i also ask please um the replacement
trees are part of the landscaping i take
it
to be could the replacement trees be
mature trees and not uh
just a small replacements which will
take a number of years
to grow uh i think that would be better
beneficial and and would certainly help
to
um lessen the impact of the building
thank you chair
thank you councillor and uh annabelle
can you come back on that
tutorial yes i can i'm
not a tree um officer so i don't know
the precise details of
the categories a b and c but nonetheless
they run with a being the best
and most um established and
healthy trees and of the most aesthetic
value
um down to c which are a lesser quality
and not considered to be as important
visually
and aesthetically and they could be
considered to be of a lesser quality
and on this particular site no category
a trees were have found and there was
one category b
tree on the site which was um
defined as category b because of its
unusual
species as well as its prominent
location
in terms of the replacement trees
if they are included in condition six of
the report which
relates to ecological enhancements and
details and to be submitted and agreed
so it could and that industry include
details of the replacement trees
so we could look to secure mature trees
at that stage or to sort of
um ensure that we do not lose um
mature trees and gain you know very
small
trees that don't necessarily have at
this moment
um aesthetic uh an equivalent aesthetic
value so i think there is scope within
condition six as it stands to
agree details of those replacement trees
both means councilman in that case chair
providing i think that the officers can
agree or get get the agreement from
the school to uh plant mature trees in
in place of the three that's been
removed
i would most happily uh support this
application thank you
chair uh thank you for that council but
i was going to come
to say myself that we could or an
officer could come back to you on
the categories of the trees but um
i think you have an answer there though
thank you very much um
councillor zesky thank you chair yeah
i'd like to uh
state my support for this application um
school and uh sports halls in schools
and that are very
key to communities and they they're
often rented out
uh to to interested parties um
as they say for badminton clubs judo
clubs etc etc and having a small kitchen
uh is not a bad thing um as for the
licensing we do have a licensing
committee that can deal with all those
kind of things and i don't think that
that should really
uh be an issue for us our issue i think
is
is purely whether or not the building is
right
uh i do think it's right the school have
looked at it the government funding is
there we should go ahead with this
uh without any hesitation thank you
chair
thank you you've taken some words from
me there councillor zesky with the
licensing board
um if that situation does arise
obviously that they would have to have a
look at that um councillor garner
thank you yeah well i had a couple of
points i wanted to make you've clarified
one around the licensing
um i mean on the whole i agree with the
other
counsellors who's spoken i agree with
councillor bailey
this is a on the whole a very good
proposal good for the um
good for the neighbourhood and good for
the town um
i share others concerns around the loss
of
these category sea trees which
according to the um that what i've got
in front of me category c trees are
trees of low quality
with an estimated remaining life
expectancy of at least 10 years
or young trees with a stem diameter
below 150 millimeters
so i guess these are the more the former
than the latter
and i would like to see um some mature
trees placed there rather than
small saplings um instead and i'm sure
that the um the broad stairs town
council tree warden i'm certain would be
more than happy
to work with the um developer to make
sure that appropriate trees
are placed on the site there thank you
uh thank you councillor ghana uh
councillor paul moore
yes thank you chair obviously being far
down the list most of my points have
already been covered
um i just like to give my point that i'm
in full
a support of this application i agree
with councillor auburn garner and
rosetsky
regarding mature trees and
the fact that this will be a community
asset a school asset
and it will develop and enhance the
well-being of all the children at that
school
um and i also agree with councillor
ghana that
will town council tree warden can
obviously support the developer
in identifying the type of trees that
are best suitable for the area
and as long as they are mature and
substantial they will last for
for eternity as long as the building
will be so all those points
have been covered so i'm fully in
support of it thank you
thank you councillor moore uh councillor
hart
thank you chair um i i do think it's a
good
a good um general overview of what
should be going on
i have slight concerns about mature
trees because a mature tree could cost
um depending on size it could cost a
couple of thousand pounds so i think
that's a bit excessive
um i think what we need to do here is um
think of the children at school
rather than spending thousands on mature
trees to go in
um a good sized sapling would be
more beneficial to the pupils than to
the
general concept of the building and the
the look of the place
and i don't think we need to go for
overly mature trees um i'd rather money
spend on the children just have a small
sapling going in
to be honest um but that's just my
personal view sorry
no problem with cancer heart uh thank
you for that um
i can't see any other members wishing to
speak uh so members i'm going to put
this to you which is uh
obviously recommendation for approval
uh once again i'm going through your
names
if you're for please say so or against
or you're abstaining uh please let me
know
uh councillor coleman cook
for councillor alban four
councillor bayford four
councillor curry four councillor ghana
four councillor heart forger
councillor four i will
try counselor pat moore whether she has
joined us
i'm not sure whether she has
no okay counselor paul moore for
chair councillorski for
councillor scott forte
councillor wright torture
myself i'm four i believe that
is unanimous and carried thank you very
much members right moving on now
to item for
d i hope i've got the right order here
with me a
new stuff down on the floor which i
shouldn't item four see a bigger pardon
uh which is the garden cottage derlock
minster
i would ask our officers to read out a
public speaking statement
in favor of the application suki
please thank you chair yes this is a
statement
in favor from mr erington who's the
agent
this public speaking presentation
relates solely to the listed building
aspects
of the development it is fully accepted
that planning legislation
requires regard to be had to the
desirability of preserving
listed buildings their setting and any
features of special
or historic interest which they possess
it is further acknowledged that great
weight should be given to these matters
when weighing up the impact to proposed
development upon designated
heritage assets it is however considered
to be vitally important that due regard
should be had to these matters based
upon the facts of each individual case
in this instance the two features to be
lost comprise a modern
window installed as part of a 1970s
extension
excuse me and a bay window introduced in
the early 2000s in connection with a
later edition
consented in 1999. whilst it is
recognized that the 1970s
window was in place at the point in time
when the building is first
listed it cannot be agreed that it
therefore enjoys a degree of heritage
significance
worthy of its retention its presence
when the building was first listed
in 1986 does not alter the fact that it
formed part of a single story flat
felt root extension which could very
well have been built under permitted
development
as without the listing in place consent
would only have been required if it had
exceeded a certain volume
also while it was designed to reflect
the windows in the older part of the
property
its size position and relationship with
other features at the rear of the
property
are such that it does not appear
cohesive with the rest of the building
the same conclusion must also be reached
in respect to the bay window
which was introduced even later and
being constructed of a mixture of
upvc and timber cannot either be
regarded as possessing
any heritage significance since it has
only been present
for some 20 years which is not
considered to represent a significant
period of time
relative to the age of the main listed
building of some 300 years
the applicants fully understand that the
evolution of a listed building can form
an important element of the significance
of the heritage asset
in this case the later edition of the
boundary wall and outbuilding
however these were added in the 18th and
early 19th centuries and by virtue of
their age
positively contribute to the historic
significance of the asset
correspondingly it is equally and widely
acknowledged
that far more contemporary additions do
not contribute
to significance to the same extent or
indeed at all which is the situation
with the features in question here
which are neither historic nor relate to
the historic layout of the listed
building
it can therefore only be concluded that
there will be no loss of historic fabric
arising from this development more
quantum historic significance
and thereby no conflict with nppf
paragraphs 193 or 196.
have you finished
hello oh yes richard yes i finished it
sorry sookie you suddenly stopped and uh
yes yes i should have
no don't worry thank you very much uh um
councillor pugh as wall councillor
please
thank you chair um i think i think that
statement um
sums up a lot of the reasons why i think
they should be um
granted permission far better than i
will be able to say but i
i will try my best and as as many of you
know from reading the uh the agenda and
the report
i called this in as one of the ward
councillors
one of my many reasons for doing so was
that i believe that actually
um this application will do more good
than harm for the local area
and whilst i understand and appreciate
that the cottage itself is situated
within
the minster conservation area um very
familiar with the area
and particularly with um
part of this kind of extension link to
the cottage um many of you may or may
not know that from church road itself
it's very hard to see um into this
property
um and and the negative impact that
uh that this change could do uh to the
surrounding area cena's is a very large
brick wall
and i invite many of the committee to
have a look on google street view
to see that the google car when it went
round many years ago
uh struggled to see properly over the
wall and to see this um
this small link extension and i think
the the new one
if it's approved tonight uh will be very
much the same um
again as i stated previously the stash
window dates from the 1970s
with pvc um i don't think that
continue to have this in the building
provides any real architectural merit
or heritage um and for that as well as
many other reasons i would urge
uh the planning committee to grant
permission for this application
tonight uh thank you very much uh
councillor pugh
um whilst the planning officer which i
believe is in
on this occasion to outline the report
thank you chair i'll just present my
screen
okay hopefully members can see the
screen
now so this application is for
listed building consent um just to make
it absolutely clear to members this is
considering the impact on the listed
building
only for for this application
um so members will be aware that um
section 66 of the listed building
conservation area
uh conservation area act 1990 requires
the local authority
uh to um to have a presumption or duty
to preserve or enhance the
characteristic buildings with regards to
the decisions which it makes with
regards to
consent such as this um the vista
building
in question is garden cottage which is
outlined
on uh this slide here
so you've got church street which wraps
around the
the top here then looking at this aerial
view
you can see the building here itself
we'll have a look at some detailed
images which will pick up some of the
points that have been raised about
the what age the the different sections
of the building were
were developed so you can see derlock
the road runs
uh to um east to west uh you've got this
parking area here which is accesses some
units down here so
there is a route down to the rear for
vehicles and pedestrians
so um and and picking up cancer pew's
point this is
uh taken from google street view in fact
uh just a view
just showing from church street so it's
actually a slightly elevated position
so this is the listed building itself
this is actually the rear of the listed
building here
um we have some photos provided by the
applicant which show the
sort of inside the garden walls of the
listed building
so this is a view of the the front of
the listed building
so um it's a grade two listed building
um circa 1700 um the listing
includes the wall which we were just
looking at um so the view that we were
getting was
from the other side of this wall here
from
church street um as i was already been
mentioned
this building was listed in 1986
was when it was listed um in terms of
the view of the rear um i've got two
images to show you
this one shows the the roof forms of
some of the
extended elements to the rear of the
listed building
if i just skip to this image this makes
it a bit clearer so we're looking from
the other side so that view that we were
just looking at is from was from here
and so to pick up some of the points
that have been raised with regards to
the removal of the windows and the
location of the extensions the extension
proposed is a single story flat roof
extension
which would remove the the bay window
here and the
sash window here now this section of the
building here with the
with the brick um section um dates to
around the early 70s
um as has been mentioned with
um with approval being given 72
and then the listing of the building
occurred as mentioned in in 1986
this section here this glaze lean to and
the
insertion of windows including the bay
was as mentioned granted in 1999
so it was listed building concerns
granted in 1999
uh for uh these this section here
so just going around some other images
so here's another image just showing
uh this uh this part of the the extended
elements
uh this is a view so from that vehicular
access that i
mentioned earlier uh that runs around
the the back boundary of the property
this is a view of the side or the it's
the south elevation but it's the side
elevation of the building
and you can see the elements here um
including the bay window in fact um
through the current gap
in the the fence what i'll be talking
about in a minute when looking at some
of the plans are
a bit of information about what consent
has been already been granted for in
this building so that members are
aware of that uh so just to go back and
recap that photo
was from outside the site is from this
location here looking back
towards the building so we're from down
here looking back towards
so this is um
a site plan showing the layout as
approved last year in a
planning application and listed building
consent so
um this element here which is the
extension that we were
just looking at part of the
extended part that we're now considering
today was removed from the application
uh but there are has been approval given
for
uh an expansion of the single story
element at the moment with some dawn
windows going in
as well as um if i click on
as well as a new boundary wall in this
section here the courtyard
and also some resurfaced turning error
and you will have seen from that image
that that started to be
implemented uh so just looking again at
the
the key part and consideration for
members on this one um this is the area
which would be altered so
this is a ground floor plan showing the
bay window
and the existing sash window
what's proposed is that a flat roof
extension would remove those two
openings and would extend
out
and then this is the roof plan just
showing so this
is the consented development here
uh for with the dorm windows at first
floor uh and you'll see that this
would extend out to link to the overhang
with the flat roof element increasing
um and so this is the side elevation so
you'll recall the photo
with the view of this so here's the bay
window and if you
in the same area you can see it's been
replaced by a
set of windows with the flat roof
extension extending out
and then this is a view that's been
provided um apologies for the labeling
it's not the existing
as such um because it's part of the
consented scheme that's there
um when it was submitted and you can see
that the
you can see a little little change
that's been shown there in terms of
again
the 3d perspective that's been given to
remove the
window that's present just to show you a
street scene so
i mentioned about the wall that had been
created um
they've been approved is here gated
access that we looked through
is here so this is the area of the
the building that's being changed and
this is a
perspective view that's been given which
is showing the
the change in situ so the flat roof
element across here has been extended
further
um in terms of close proximity with the
road
so going through again some of the other
visualizations that's been provided
the flat roof element on the top image
here that's being extended
um is is this bit here and this is an
image just showing again this is the
consented
development but you can see this outcrop
that's here
is where the flat roof element um
protrudes out
and then this is just a view just
showing that it's it's not visible
from viewpoints from church street
because of the presence of the elements
which we looked at
on the uh on the previous slides and
images
um so in the view of the conservation
officer
um and the officer in this instance um
the the concern is really raised to the
the protrusion of the flat roof element
out from the existing um obviously it's
acknowledged that
um as has been very clearly outlined
these windows are not original to the
building they're not from the
1700s though they are considered to
have a certain element of merit in terms
of the character of the property in
terms of the
the especially in terms of this sash
windows the quality
of the work that's been put in however
it is understood that
the particular concerns have been raised
about it doesn't constitute the loss of
historic fabric however
the actual windows themselves um you
know are considered to contribute
towards the character of the property
and as the conservation officer is
outlined the character list of buildings
do
change over time um and the protrusion
out of a flat roof
element um into and and
um almost blocking the rear elevation of
the building
um is considered to result in in some
harm it has been acknowledged in the
report though this is less than
substantial
however any harm to a listed building
um has got to be weighed against the
public benefits
of the proposal and in this instance
there are no public benefits
from the proposal and therefore
um you know the protrusion of the flat
roof element um is considered to intrude
on the rear elevation of the listed
building
um and therefore is considered to
detrimentally affect
the character of the listed building and
therefore office of recommendation is
is for refusal in this instance thank
you chair
uh thank you ian um right i move that
the officer's recommendation that you've
heard is to refuse could the vice chair
please
second i'll second nature
thank you council column cook um a
councillor alban
yeah thank you chair it's a it's a um
i i don't know this property at all but
having
looking at it at the rear
it's a hodgepodge of uh it's a hot spot
of buildings as far as i can see to a
layman if you like
um i don't see
uh the merit of either the bay window
uh the sash window a bit more but the
bay window i don't really see as a merit
there
uh that actually enhances the existing
listed building or which it's attached
to
um so over overall chair i
i i can't see why i
could agree to go with the officer's
recommendation and i i
i don't know i don't go along with it
thank you chair
uh thank you councillor and councillor
hart
thank you chair um as you may know i'm a
ward councillor for this uh area
uh together with rhys um i must admit
when when you look at this building it's
a lovely building and i think that
um i must disagree totally with the
planning officers because i feel that
the
um making it squared off and looking
nice
presents building in a much better way i
think people have to
learn to adapt these great two listed
buildings to be a
livable and sensible way to live and i
think that the
um to use council auburn's words
hodgepodge of
extensions that have gone on it over the
past few years decades
um don't enhance the building at all and
in fact
by doing this one uh new proposal i
think it will make it a much nicer
usable building thank you thank you
councillor hart uh councillor joel
bakeford
thank you chair um i i do agree with um
the comments from councillor auburn and
councillor hart
um my uh yeah hodgepodge mishmash was
what what i was going to say
it does look a little bit of mess to be
honest i think the bay looks odd
there i love bay windows but i don't
think it look
it looks good there um and i think to be
honest the the flat roof extension will
only
improve the aesthetics of the building
so
um i i can't really support
refusal of this application thank you
thank you councilman for the councillor
moore paul moore
yes thank you chair um it's all just
been said by the previous councillors
i think the present condition of the
building is a mishmash
um and it doesn't look particularly nice
i think what the developer and the
owners of proposed
brings uniformity and blends the
building into one
um my only uh my only
question would be from the slides that
mr livingston showed the new windows
are single glazed and don't seem to
blend in with what's in the building at
the moment
on the the new bit that we were talking
about and the existing and
by that i mean the georgian style
windows with the beadings
and and to have those on those glazings
will just blend it in
and make it look more uh more uniformity
and i'm a great person for that
i like to see things matching and i
think that would just set that whole
rear off
a lot better but i cannot agree with the
planning officer's recommendation
thank you chair uh thank you councillor
moore
i don't see that there are any other
speakers
um on this application so
members it's over to you you've heard
the recommendation
is refusal once again i'm going to have
to call your names out
um if you're for refusal please say so
if you're against
or you're abstaining please let me know
um
councillor coleman cook for
council steve robin against
councillor bayford against councillor
curry
against councillor ghana
for councillor heart against
councillor keane against councillor paul
moore
against councillor ryozevsky
against council scott against
council right against and i'm against
that as well
so um that promotion has been
lost um so right in uh
mr livingston can we come back to you
absolutely thank you so um in terms of
proposing
a new motion um to approve the scheme
um on the back of the vote um it's i
just think it's important to start to
summarize
um that members a number of members have
mentioned about how
the proposed development would actually
in their view enhance
the character of the the listed building
in terms of the
the what it would do to assist in sort
of tidying up the rear
of the property so if a motion is put
forward for approval if the member that
does so
could simply just state that on the
ground
that it would it would preserve and
enhance
the the character of the listed building
thank you
uh thank you ian um you've heard mr
levinson's
advice there members um
can i have a proposal for that please
oh go away yeah just carry on
one i'm lost who came first
catch you more thank you council
my youth got got to the button quicker
right
uh classroom uh second i'll second that
chat thank you right
have to go through obviously that once
again members
you've heard the new proposition to
the application let's go through your
names again
sorry to interrupt chairman but uh mr
livingston
would like the motion to be uh red
chair yeah sorry thank you thank you
thank you chair
sorry just just to confirm then i think
just to make absolutely clear for
everyone
watching that the motion that i was
making clear that's been proposed and
seconded is to approve the application
uh on the grounds that alone would
preserve and enhance
the characteristic building thank you
chair
uh thank you ian um i do know councillor
ghana has put conditions does that cover
your query there council ghana
well i'm sorry i'm not sure
i know we sort of had this discussion
last time but when
when a an application comes before us
for approval
there's a long list of conditions that
have been put put on the application for
us to approve
now we've used it and we've proven it
now
there aren't any conditions there like
the standard ones
or have the planning officers considered
other conditions that they
if they were gonna suppose that we
accept this
what would be the planning conditions
they would want us to approve
that's like so i don't know the answer
just that's my
question that maybe mr livingston can
help you i'll come back to you in but i
believe we're gonna
touch on that in the next item but um
well yes i i can i can pick up
um on that point so when um
under delegated authority after a an
application is is granted by members
um there is delegated authority to put
on safeguarding conditions but indeed as
councillor ghana points out it is much
better in in committee meetings such as
this that
that we can state that sort of firmly so
um in terms of safeguarding conditions
the
there will be a standard time condition
and we would look to impose
conditions which related to the the
previous approval
and that would include joinery details
to be provided of the new timber windows
for example uh as well as samples of
materials
to be provided so those are the
safeguarding conditions that we would
put on this type of application just to
confirm
for members knowledge
thank you for that ian um if that
answers councillor
councillor moore does that answer your
only in as much chair that um where
we're saying we wish it to preserve and
enhance the building
and we put a condition that the windows
uh
match the style of the remainder of the
building
so that it blends in because at the
moment you've got georgian
georgian effect on the back georgian
effect on the new build
and then you've got single glaze in the
middle uh and i think that just breaks
it up and i don't think it looks right
maybe we could put that as a condition i
don't know what the other members think
of
well i'll come to you and um
so members if the motion is
obviously the motion that's been put
forward is to approve the development in
front of members
so that is the plans that members have
been shown
so it wouldn't allow for a change to the
design
of those plans that members have seen
this evening
if that was wished and that by majority
was put forward that need
you know an amended plan needs to be
submitted it would have to be deferred
back to officers to seek that amended
plan
and then potentially approved on that
basis or bore back to members
so it's it's about whether or not
members are moving a motion to approve
what they've seen or whether or not
they're putting forward
um for additional and amended plans to
be submitted about the design of the
window itself on that side of the nation
thank you chair thank you anne um
obviously members you've heard
uh the advice there um we do have a
proposal and a second uh
uh for the new application or what's
been
put forward but now you've heard miss
livingston's
thoughts if you wish that to change
and it comes back to committee at
another stage
chairman's chair please yes councillor
auburn
um i think we should just uh there is an
epic
the application that we've looked at and
we've seen it
we've seen what's there we've all
decided that we've
that uh or not all but it's been decided
that uh we
we wish to go forward and approve this
list of building consent
and i think we should stick with what is
there what was shown
on the plans thank you chair yes thank
you for that counselor auburn um
council chair um what council in light
of mr slimmington's just said
um i've attracted what i said about the
windows it's what's in front of us
and i'm for what's in front of us thank
you chair thank you for that councilman
moore
uh so moving on to the vote uh you've
heard the new proposition
um those who are for against
or abstaining please let me know uh
councilman cook
four counts robin four
councillor joe bayford councillor curry
four councillor ghana
tour councillor heart georgia
councillor keane four councilman
paul moore fall chair councillor
zesky for councillor scott
porter cancer right for chair
and i am as well so that
has been carried thank you very much
members
right moving on to item 4d
which is uh gained garden derlock
minster
i'll ask you here we would read out a
statement please thank you chair
this is from mr errington the agent
this presentation relates to the
planning aspects of the development
incorporating design principles visual
impact and relationship to the
conservation area
in terms of design submissions
circulated to members demonstrate that
as far as the slash window in the rear
elevation of the 1970s extension is
concerned
there is no symmetry to the rear
elevation other than
the fact that the first floor rear dorma
is centrally located
and is flanked symmetrically by equally
sized windows
however the ground floor features do not
relate to each other
or the features above in terms of height
width proportions or position
whilst the sash window to be removed is
largely obscured from view by the
existing
rear outbuilding for which consents have
been granted
to enlarge and which will further
obscure any view of the window
similarly there are no features on the
listed building
or its aggressions which relate in
design terms
to the bay window which was consented in
1999
but which has been finished in upvc and
timber
the proposed kitchen edition will
therefore be finished in feather edge
timber cladding which will not only be
more in keeping with the character of
the wider building
but will balance with and match the
cladding already approved upon the
extended outbuilding
to the right hand side of the entrance
hall in this respect the kitchen window
will project
no further outwards than the front
elevation of the rear outbuilding as
extended
the flat roof will form a minor
continuation of the existing flat roof
of the rear extension and the new window
will reflect the proportions of the
entrance wall door glazing
which has previously been approved by
the council turning to the conservation
area it is important to note
from the officers report that local plan
policy
states within section 7 that in
applications for extensions to buildings
in conservation areas
the policy requires that the character
scale and
platform of the original building are
respected and the development is
subordinate to
it and does not dominate to principal
elevations
members will have seen from the
circulated photographic assessment
and as has been confirmed by the
applicants independent heritage
consultant
the areas of the building the subject of
the council's concern
relate to part of the extension
constructed in the 1970s and a later
edition
approved by the council in 1999.
neither element is therefore part of the
original building
and nor are they directly attached to or
directly associated with
the main property indeed the use of
feather egg
timber cladding will integrate more
satisfactorily
with the out rear outbuilding and
provide a uniform and coherent built
form
beyond the 1970s extension it is
therefore considered
that the proposals are acceptable in
terms of design appearance and materials
the work will be virtually invisible
from any public point of view
which is only from a private access road
and as such
the development is not contrary to the
local plan policies
qd 02 or he 02 or
nppf paragraphs 193 and 196. thank you
chair
thank you very much suki um council for
you as wall councillor you wish to speak
thank you chair yes um i'll try not to
go over
um everything i said again but i suppose
it may be easier for
the committee if i do repeat a few
points um again i called in this
application because i feel that
um that these changes will actually
enhance the local area
uh rather than um and essentially ruined
it
ruin it um as many of the panel members
will know this is included within the
minster conservation area
but i think as you've seen from the
previous
application 4c
that actually the improvements that this
will do to the property i think are
quite substantial and you know
let's not forget that this is a family
that bought this property
um they want it to suit modern needs and
i think as council auburn said in the
previous um application about
um about the the listed nature of the
building you know it's a bit of a
hodgepodge
as a building you know over the years
certain elements have been added you
know there's a few little bits that kind
of jut
out and i think that that adds more to
the character of the building itself um
you know and i think us as a council i
think it's our duty to of course
um ensure that things are in keeping
with their surrounding area but as i
mentioned
particularly with the brick wall um
along uh church road church street
um you know and and how very little of
this can be seen
um of the public as they as they walk by
i think that i would urge this planning
committee to
grant uh permission for this application
uh thank you very much uh council um
i believe um it's over to you okay
yes thank you chair i will just present
my screen um
so just to um just to give members the
context of this application
so this is the application for planning
permission for the development that that
has just been approved
so the consideration is different from
the previous application for
for sorry the listed building consent
that's just been approved um
so this is considering the impact on the
conservation area and so just to show
members where the conservation area
is so here's the property in question so
this
is the property in question on a sort of
rather more basic plan
form but just showing that it's within
the conservation area
and the access that's been mentioned
that runs down uh
the the rear of the property is also in
the conservation area as well
um so these are the images that we
looked at earlier
so the element is in this area here
these are the windows in the bay window
that we've just talked about
um and this is one of the viewpoints um
so this is from that sort of access
where you've got the cars parked here
you know where you will you know you'll
go get um
views of the extension that's being
proposed
um so the concern that officers have
raised here
is the views are possible from from the
outside of the site and even with the
boundary revisions that were part of the
2020 application and you know whilst
this
this extension is set against other
elements it is still considered that the
expansion of the flat roof element
across the rear of the property
will affect the contribution the
building has within the conservation
area
and and on that basis and without the
public benefits to outweigh the
the harm is recommended for refusal
on that basis thank you chair uh thank
you ian
um i move for the officer's
recommendation
is for refusal could i have a second to
please uh
vice chairman all second nature
uh thank you council former members
that we wish to discuss this council
robin
yeah sorry to be first again chair
uh i i again i i i don't see
that this extension uh would detract
from the conservation area chair
um i i think it's it's mainly shielded
um the access road that runs down the
side of
the rear you know it's not a highly used
access it's not really seen by the
general public as you would buy so there
would be no
in my opinion there would be no
particular detriment
to the conservation area so as far as
i'm concerned here
i will be going against the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you for that council robin um i
can't see
any other speakers
right members and i will say this i know
we're being live streamed on
the council's youtube channel we do have
a procedure so
for members of the public who are
watching and
hear me go through the names of the
members
this is what we have to do so um
it may sound to members sometimes a
little bit
too repetitious but it has to be done um
i put this to you that uh recommendation
is for refusal once again
if you're voting for that or against or
abstaining please let me know
uh councillor coleman cook against
council alban against councillor
against councillor curry against
councillor ghana four councillor heart
against yeah councilman keane
against councillor paul moore
against chair councillor zesty
against councillor scott against
council right against uh
myself i'm against as well
so that motion has been lost
so therefore we've got to come back um
can i come back to you ian yes so same
same principle as the last item chair
with this
one if a member is proposing a motion um
you know
made clear from the previous debate
carried over in terms of the visibility
of this that it's not considered
to result in harm to the character of
the the conservation area
and and that is sort of taken as the
reason why any motion for approval would
be put forward on those grounds
thank you chair thank you ian uh members
uh once again you heard mr livingston's
advice there
um i don't know whether you wish him to
read that out again but could i have if
not could i have a proposal please
i know you always come first counselor
auburn but you know
who did propose it council paul moore
thank you councillor moore can i have a
second to please
thank you right once again at that
dreaded list of names uh please so
you've heard them here's the secondary
apologies i missed that one
a councillor auburn
lovely thank you right once to gain
members
your dreaded list of names um you've
heard that
motion put forward which is now
for um please
answer if you would keep uh councillor
coleman cook
for council robin four
councillor jill bayford four councillor
curry
four councillor ghana against
council my heart orchard counselor keen
four mr paul moore
four councillorski or
counselor scott walter councillor right
fortune and
i'm four as well so that motion
has been passed thank you very much
members for that
um okay uh
agenda item number four e which is
margate football ground hearts down road
margate i'm going to politely say this
because we're being listened to uh but
could
councillor auburn please leave the
meeting
i'm on my way in the garden stroll
around in cliftonville have a look
around
uh steve okay the reason being
that uh if members are publicly
listening um
council auburn has declared an interest
in
the market football club application
i'll ask an officer
which i believe is in once again
who sorry an officer who's got a public
speaking statement i'm sorry
uh of an objection to this application
thank you chair yes this is a statement
objecting from mr
arves whilst i
am in principle in support of a hotel in
the development of margate football club
i do believe the current plan as it
stands is in the wrong location
and will be better served in the
previously agreed planning consent
fth-110428
granted in december 2011. due to the
size design and decor
of the proposed hotel and stands they
will be visible
all year from heartstown park tivoli
park and tivoli park
avenue despite the planting of trees
which has taken place
as these are not expected to mature for
30 years
they will be an intrusive addition to
the open
space currently enjoyed i'm pleased to
see that many of the concerns i
originally raised
have been noted and conditions attached
to the planning consent
should this application be granted i do
remain concerned over hotel residents
privacy when the grounds are in use
particularly when floodlights are used
however i believe of greater concern now
is the landscaping of tivoli
park that is being undertaken and has
resulted in the loss of playing fields
within the park
it is by phanet district council's own
admission that there is a shortage of
playing fields in the district
and the loss of any playing area should
be of great concern to
all i note that it is the council's plan
to concentrate
playing active facilities at jackie
baker's that's in the district plan
2020-2021 this however has serious
implications on the children of margate
who are unable to travel to ramsgate due
to family circumstances
lack of income and or no private
transport
and by definition are likely to greatly
benefit from
sports facilities accessible by foot
i would also like to advise the council
that the playing pitch
which has now been lost was in regular
use by the youth connected
to margate football club in 2018
2019 and during the period between
lockdowns in 2020
when they carried the portable goal
posts from the rear of the football
stadium
onto the park to play so despite margate
football club
actively wanting to lose this area
they are currently demonstrating there
is a present need for this playing
facility
the loss of a sizeable area of tivoli
park to enable the development of the
hotel
was not included in the plans posted
online until october 2020
a considerable time after public
comments were closed
the park belongs to and is paid for by
the residents of phanet
but they were not given an opportunity
to express their views on effectively
losing the park
in an extension to tivoli woods the tree
planting was undertaken without any
prior notice
and i note that the planning officer has
stated that it did not require planning
permission to do this
just because you can can it doesn't mean
you should
residents deserve to be consulted on a
major loss of parkland
there are better areas park which the
trees could be planted
which do not result in the loss of
playing fields
i would strongly recommend the committee
refuses application as it
stands and requests that the developer
considers
alternative options which do not impinge
on the park
or playing fields thank you chair
uh thank you very much suki um
planning officer which i believe is ian
thank you in thank you i will just
present my screen
okay um so the planning application for
members
is an application for the erection of a
120 bed hotel which comprises of two
stands uh which incorporates
uh a hotel uh associated
uh restaurant um and other facilities
uh and then there's a a club shop
there's
a um then there's changing rooms
um with cafe at first floor
on one of them and ancillary facilities
for uh
club offices etc um there is a
significant amount of planning history
on this particular site which members
would have seen in the agenda
and it includes extend planning
permission from the permission that was
originally granted in 2004
which was implemented and then
subsequently has been varied
in various ways throughout the process
but this this
application in front of members is a new
application
for consideration the main issues are
the principle of development the impact
on the character appearance of the area
highways loss of of playing pitches
playing field
impacts on the environment living
conditions and as well as the
economic and social considerations of
the application
so this is the site outlined in red
so you've got hearthstone road here so
um this is so the north's actually on
the right hand side here
most of you will know hearthstone park
here
so this is just an aerial view showing
the football club at the moment
set inside the park um
this is a an image just showing the
football club
but just to give you the reference point
in terms of where it is located
in terms of uh margot main sands
at the train station which is in this
area
here you've got tippie park avenue here
and coffeehouse corner is here
and then this is just another view just
showing uh the established tree lines
that you've got
in in the park as well as
a footpath route which we're going to
talk about which runs through from
hearts down
to tivoli park avenue
so this is a view from the front of the
site
um looking this is the between the car
park and the car park
if i just go back the car park was one
of the implemented elements of the 2004
uh consent so um this has been obviously
as part of the implementation of that
scheme um so you can see actually the
footpath that i just mentioned running
down between the football club and the
car park
uh so that is a public right of way as
protected by by kcc
uh this is a view looking from the park
um
to what what is effectively the east of
the site
so you can see a collection of buildings
at the moment which are located
adjacent to the pitch uh with the car
park behind the railings
in the foreground this is a view looking
back towards the road so you can just
here
might be able to just see the signage
for the for the football club
uh just showing some of the trees that
are there as well as the relationship
with the road
uh so that's those buildings on the the
eastern part of the football ground
so this is a view taken showing the
corner of the site um to the the
fullest of the uh eastern northern
extent
with some of the trees that are
currently present on the site
if i just click on then i'll show you
where we were looking at we're looking
at
this area in the bottom right of the
image here was where we were just
looking at you can actually see the
single story
structure that you can see with the
graffiti on the previous image
so what we're just going to do is we're
going to look at this northern
uh elevation uh existing to show the
the existing trees that are present
along here
so this is the view along you've got see
series of mature trees but then you've
also got
uh quite a scrub below that
and then if you're walking all the way
along here you get to the uh
the the fiber side pitches um some to
the
to the west of the football club um
and then turning back uh just shows you
the other view of those
um you know trees that are present along
the boundary of the site and you can see
the railings
just through here that run all the way
along that delineates the actual
football ground itself
uh so now we're just going to look at
this area of land
here um which is the
the bit of of the pitch or the the bit
of the the park
to be lost by the proposal
um so this is the at the moment the car
park that's there so
part of the land to be uh developed is
is in this part of the image here so
then
moving back you can see the full extent
of the the sort of square or rectangular
section
that forms part of the application site
mentioned has been made of of these
trees that have been planted
so these trees have not been planted
within the application site and they
haven't been parted as
part of the application this has been
done separately
um i believe in agreement between the
football club
and tdc estates um to be able to plant
these trees so they don't form
part of the application itself
uh and so this is a view from behind
those trees but showing that section of
land
where the proposed car park would be
developed
and this is just another view further
back again showing that the bank of
trees
the other side of which is the car park
and the area that's proposed to be
developed
so this is an image from
the other revisions to the 20 uh
to sorry 2004 application that was
approved and that 2004 application
was approved for an 80 bed hotel with
new stands to the north and the east
with
various sort of functions including
leisure facilities fitness club cafe and
ancillary facilities
linked to the hotel so it's a similar
proposal to what's been put forward
but with certain key elements changed
one of those elements that's
that's changed is that this is the car
park that was approved
uh in the one of the revisions in in
2012
um you will see that um
this proposes for the the car park to
extend
through that open space that we were
just looking at and the the what's
classed as
public open space um and also extending
actually further out than the northern
boundary of the football club
um with with more parking and it's also
it's it's
it's it's slightly sort of slightly
wider as well
than what's what you'll see is being
proposed at the moment
um the permissions are extend so they
can be
continued and implemented at any time
and we'll come on to why that's relevant
as when we're talking about the loss of
playing pictures um
these are elevations from two separate
applications the top one is an elevation
from the 2011
application which has already been rent
referenced and this is the east
elevation of what has been approved
for for an 80 bed hotel
as part of that approval again that is
part of an extent permission
and then this is showing on the bottom
of the image is showing the north stand
from outside the site
uh looking in um so with you know the
trees
effectively would be in front of this uh
um
you know elevation of the north stand at
the bottom here um
and again that is part of the extent
permissions on the site
so in terms of the proposal um as
mentioned 120 bed hotel which is located
in the eastern stand
here the eastern stand would also um
have seated accommodation well seated um
spectator areas of about 650 seats
the northern stand which primarily
is um in studio space for use
um including east the community but also
has changing facilities for the football
club
on the first floor has a cafe but also
has
a terrace capacity of
i think 1 300 terrace capacity for
seating so
it does include an increase in the
seated or standing accommodation for
the football ground the south
and uh so the south and west parts of
the football club
are remaining as as currently so there's
no proposal in front of members at this
point for
development of those those sections
the car park as proposed is in the
bottom of the image here
um what's being proposed here is 104 car
parking spaces for the hotel and the
ancillary facilities
with a coach parking turning area uh at
the
this sort of what's the north east
of the site um
so i'm just going to go through the
elevations of the proposed eastern stand
these elevations are having to be split
into two because of the
the size of them and so that members can
actually see them
um but there are some perspectives that
we'll look at
so this is if you've just entered the
car park and you are looking to the left
this is the the closest to the road
element of the the buildings this is the
the elevation that fronts the car park
and so it's
a four-story building at its highest
point but three-story
in the majority and the materials that
propose to aluminium windows with
cladding panels in in blue to match the
the colors of the football club
um with a sort of breeze soleil feature
um to try and break up the elevation
here
as well as brickwork uh a ground floor
and in the central four-story element
um here um and just looking over you can
see that then the full-story element
continues
on with another one of the um the sort
of solar shading
elements to be white before it then
drops down
uh to a single story when then it turns
the corner into what becomes then the
the north
stand of the building so these the
elevations that front the car park
um this is the back of the elevation we
just saw
obviously you can see uh the the seating
arrangements for the
football ground itself uh and then this
is the other side so you can see that
central
four-story brick element in in this part
of the screen here
and then this is the roadside
i suppose facing the south of the site
so facing hearts down road
um the elevation that you get you can
see they've
added in the the bracelet features here
and then the other relevation so this is
facing the parks this is the north
of the site
so this is a perspective that's been
provided by the applicant so it's
it's a representation um but it's useful
to just see the context of
of the different articulations in built
form that are being proposed so it's not
a flat frontage all the way along the
full extent of this building
it does protrude in and out with
canopies depending on where the
entrances are and where the different
building elements
are situated and there's another view
there so you can actually see the main
entrance point here and the way that the
building is set in a different point
uh to break up the mass of what's been
proposed
um so just going through the floor plans
of this eastern section of the building
so this element here which is the ground
floor
closest to the road is the restaurant in
association with the hotel you can see
on the right hand side here
this is the lobby area of the hotel and
if i just click onto the next part
you can see sorry about this splitting
up the slides um which is the
for the plans you can see this sort of
breakfast area
for the hotel as well and some of the
back room um
parts of the hotel in this area here
this uh section of the building is for
club offices
for the football club with a club shop
um
which is located here
then moving through the elevations as
mentioned it's a
120 bed hotel so you've got rooms on the
first floor in this section
and also the first floor on the second
section so you see the relationship with
the car park
here with then the second floor as well
with a number of bedrooms and then this
section here again
showing the bedrooms that located on the
second floor
and then the third floor obviously has
that section in the center
which is primarily for um you know
it's got some additional bedrooms that
are here but also has some plant
equipment
and maintenance rooms
and then this is the roof plan what's
been proposed here is for solar panels
on the roof as well
and this is just showing the roof forms
and how they connect
so moving on to the the proposed north
stand so as mentioned
this includes a um you know cafe at
first floor but with also
changing facilities um so this top set
top view is the actual view from the the
football pitch
so this is showing you see the terraced
areas on the ground floor here
uh with the windows serving the cafe at
first floor and then uh the image at the
bottom is showing the view that
um would be the elevation which would
face towards
the the park
and these are the side elevations of
that part of the building
and then the floor plans as mentioned
the studio space here on the ground
floor with
changing facilities and then the the
cafe
uh in this location on the first floor
here
and this is just the roof plan and so to
just pick up points about
landscaping so this is the landscaping
plan
that was submitted um just to outline
just to pick up one of the points has
been raised in the public speaking
the um details of the actual
loss of the playing picture so the site
plan that we've seen earlier was part of
the public consultation so
no addition has been made during the
course of the application no
additional loss of playing pictures has
been
it sort of introduced through the
process
uh in this instance so consultation has
occurred
on the full extent of the car park uh
which obviously as we've seen from the
images
extends over part of the current um
playing fields that are present or
protected a public open space
so as mentioned this tree planting is is
shown to be
outside the site so whilst it may be
proposed
potentially separate to this planning
application it's not forming part of
the application in front of members
the extent of the site as mentioned goes
over this area here
so this area has been as mentioned part
of the extent permissions
um and so the report does talk about the
fact that
technically this um that area um
that's currently grasped is is under
policy gi05 um and
and it doesn't constitute one of the
sort of caveats of that policy for
protection of public open space
however um the weight to be given to
that public open space
is put forth by officers to be limited
and there's a very specific reason for
that and that is those extent
permissions
because this land is no longer in the
ownership of the district council
it's under the ownership of market
football club and it's always been
envisioned
since 2004 that that land that playing
pitch would be lost
for the proposal for the car park
throughout the years
and therefore whilst there is actually
by this proposal there is a loss
um significant weight is provided to the
extent permissions on the site
now this has been relayed to sport
england
and you will see from the correspondence
that we've received during the
application there is still an objection
to
the application from sports england what
this means is
if members were to go with the officer
recommendation
uh this evening to um defer and delegate
for approval
is that the local authority will be
required to consult with the secretary
of state
because of the objection from sports
england and to understand whether or not
the secretary of state wishes to call
the application in
uh for consideration um and or
and if they don't then we would be able
to issue the decision for approval
but if they do then obviously they would
take the authority to determine
the application so
moving through the perspectives of the
scheme and just outlining the
considerations the impact on
the character of the area um these are
images that have again been provided by
the applicant um
but um we have looked at them in terms
of the comparison between the approved
scheme which is
outlined in in red and the proposed
scheme um which is put forward to
members this evening
um so you'll see in in that the extent
of the building
does not exceed what's been proposed and
approved
in the previous consents it's simply
that the
internal arrangement has changed to
allow an increase from a 80 bed hotel to
a 120 bed
hotel so this is a perspective that's
been provided
by the applicant from from tivoli park
avenue um it is considered the
you know the building obviously would be
an increase um quite significant
increase on the fact that there is
is nothing on the site at the moment but
again members should take into account
the fact that
there is a obviously an approved consent
for a four-story building
on this site uh and also in in offices
view the scale of the building is not
uh would not dominate the open space but
would um
you know due to the openness it wouldn't
seem excessive or out of scale
in in officer's view there is another
um image here which just shows
directly that that eastern elevation of
the proposal um to pick up the points
um that the report cover um
transportation is one of the key issues
that's been looked at here and it's
had quite a lot of discussion between
kcc highways uh the applicant and
and the council um you know the site is
considered to be in a sustainable
location
it's within 800 meters or two bus stops
15 minute walk and station
provisions been made for 105 spaces
serving the hotel and the facilities
um a transport assessment has been
submitted and and has been
looked at by kcc highways have raised no
objections
uh to the amount of parking provision
that's been provided
the report also details about um the
public rights of way
so um the public right way that runs
through the site
which is tmx 13 that you can see on the
image in front of you
that's proposed as part of this scheme
to be resurfaced
and there's also a financial
contribution which was requested by kcc
for upgrading
uh the footpaths in the vicinity of the
site but linked obviously to anyone
using
all saints avenue or further to the west
to access the site
um that contribution has already been
secured by a planning obligation which
has been
submitted there's also a planning
obligation
for this type of development which is
hotel development for
uh towards the the sams so the the
contribution towards mitigation of the
special protection area
um that's calculated on a reduced rate
from normal residential accommodation to
taking into account
likely winter occupancy dropping down
number of visitors
um and that's been agreed with natural
england as per our outstanding advice
so there is the mitigation has been
secured by planning obligation
for for that part of the the the
permission or proposal um
in terms of the impact on living
conditions um it's considered that the
buildings themselves are significantly
far away from
102 hearthstone road as well as
obviously very significant
distance from from two park
proposals would be required to be
submitted to the local council for
um lighting and that would cover issues
with biodiversity
security and especially light pollution
as well because obviously it is quite
exposed elevation
so it is really important that the
lighting strategy that's provided
make sure it's paying reference to both
protected species but also the potential
spillage that you could get from
something like this there's
also um various conditions with regards
to archaeology
a lot of these conditions have been
looked at on previous consents as well
and they're detailed in the officer
report
overall in terms of the considerations
it's the view of offices that the
proposal would result in
demonstrable tourism and community
benefits as well from
both the new hotel but also the
improvements of the football club
as well as as employment from the um
hotel that would be
created from the proposal the design has
been considered to be
acceptable um and therefore whilst there
is
uh a a you know the development would
represent a departure
from policy uh gi zero five
um as involving the loss of public open
space
on a technical basis limited weight
is is provided to that loss on the basis
of the
weight to be given to the extent
permissions and therefore the
application is recommended
to be deferred and delegated for
approval subject to the safeguarding
conditions
and subject to consultation with the
secretary of state to understand whether
or not they want to
call in the application thank you chair
thank you very much
very impressive i move that the
officer's recommendation
uh and dedicate could
uh vice chair please second i'll second
that chair
uh thank you coleman cook uh councillor
joe payford
thank you chair um well the football
club has provided entertainment and
interest
to local people and visitors for many
many years
um it's inevitable that over time
improvements um extensions
will need to be made in order to um
accommodate
current demands it appears to me that a
lot of
trouble has been taken here to ensure
that
um although although it cannot be denied
that it's
it's a large um development it
um it maintains a lot the the uh
football pictures that the playing
fields that are already there
it's a fair distance from the um
the local building the nearest buildings
um with the
taking into account the extent
permissions and what seems to me very
careful
planning um for something that i think
would be a great community
benefit i think i'd like to support this
application thank you
uh thank you councilman councillor garma
yeah thank you very much yeah i have um
i do have a few concerns about
about this um proposal
um the first one it wasn't mentioned in
the report
but i see uh not only is it sports
england who are objecting to this
but can police have raised an objection
raising a number of issues
which i think ought to be addressed um
to minimize the opportunity for crime
fear of crime and
social behavior um so that that wasn't
much i
would like to hear a bit more about that
if possible but the loss of
open space is the concern to me
um sport england as you say have
objected and i
i can understand why they've objected it
seems there's
there's been a bit of not very joined up
thinking
um over the last few months or years
where we've known the land's going to be
lost the plainfields are going to be
lost
as part of this development but at the
same time
we've planted a number of trees have
been planted on
other um playing field that that has
resulted in more loss than there should
have been
and obviously i'm i'm the last person
here who's going to object to
planting of trees but they need to be
planted obviously in the right
place um another concern that i have
relates to um access and the
the roads um
that we know that coming down the coming
down the road
soon in the next few months there's
going to be a proposed development
opposite this
um the football ground in
the the site off of shotendon road for i
believe 250 houses which is obviously
going to add
to the weight of traffic in the
surrounding area
um so it's a shame these can't all be
thought of in a
in a joined up way um i just like to
finish with a with a question really i
didn't
i didn't fully understand and i i hope
maybe this image
can explain the actual ownership
of the land that is being built on
because obviously there's it well not
obviously but it looks like
land has been acquired over the years to
extend the size of this site
and i just like to understand better
where that's come from and and who owns
all of the land that's being built on
now
and so it's a couple of things there but
hopefully you can help thanks
for garnick and um i think uh i i think
honor you asked
i'll let you um thanks
i'll come back on on on the various
points
um that have been raised so um just to
pick up
um the one one of the points about um
access to the site if i start with that
one so the
the proposal would utilize the existing
access um
to the site and it has been in the
transport assessment there is
modeling showing um vehicles entering
and exiting
that um access including coaches
um and also delivery vehicles which has
been looked at on a safety basis by
by kcc um i think an important point
about the relationship with
um other applications that are in with
the council at the moment
um is obviously because it's the
existing access that's there
um you know that is obviously going to
be part of any arrangement that's put
forward on any subsequent application
for
other sites that obviously will take
into account visibility of any new
accesses in relation to the existing
accesses so
there is some you know there will be
some joined up thinking there and in
terms of
uh traffic capacity this scheme
is considered by highways to be within
the capacity of the highway network
uh subsequent applications will
obviously have to prove
in some way that their development would
also be within the capacity of the
highways network or whether or not
indeed
other other network capabilities will be
required in terms of road links etc
um in terms of the police they have
raised um
some concerns with regards to the scheme
um it has been considered that the
scheme does
have a sort of it's a it's a bit of a
balance because in regards of what
they're actually proposing here
there would clearly be improvements to
the security for example with regards to
the footpath that runs through the site
because at the moment that footpath can
be utilized across the park
without much surveillance whereas
obviously if you have a hotel and that
sort of development and the surface is
redone
with lighting etc that that would
obviously improve security to some
extent
um detailed concerns um have you know
can be
addressed through informatives because
there are sometimes often
issues that that aren't dealt with by
planning conditions because they are
are rather more about the management of
the premises in this instance the hotel
and obviously um this is something that
we would always encourage applicants
subsequent to approval to contact chem
police about certain security
arrangements and
um issues to do with with security um
to pick up the point with regards to
ownership
um the the previous
the the site previously was under the
freehold ownership of fantastic council
um that um it was the site outlined in
red
um and that's but that's no longer the
case it's now owned by the football club
so whilst on the ground when we were
looking at the squares
the square of of open space uh that open
space
is no longer under the ownership of the
the council it was part of
the overall site that was sold um
a couple years ago now um to uh so
the freehold was sold off so which is
why
in terms of the loss of playing pitches
and i take your point with regards to
the
the tree planting the tree planting
though as i mentioned is has been dealt
with by the tc estates team
um on the basis of looking at the whole
of the park
to work out you know where pitches could
be um
but in terms of what's lost in this
instance it is land that has already
been
um you know it's already been approved
for development
and that which is why we've put forward
obviously the view that we have that
actually it's
it's it's been known that this this
particular parcel have been land
would be lost for 16 years actually even
further than that because there's a 2002
application
which was for i think it was a three
thousand state uh
stadium um which would again have
resulted in a similar sort of loss so
um it hasn't been delineated on the
ground but that's why we've considered
that the loss in this instance would be
acceptable
thank you for that ian um
i have if i may uh i know i have other
speakers
uh the police are coming in on quite a
few of our applications now which um
i say obviously they have the right to
as they do with licensing and so on but
i think some of their um
possible comments um just be looks at uh
uh counselor zesky
thank you chair um looking at the design
uh of the project it looks uh
quite suitable for the area i don't see
any problem in that
i think it actually will be a great
investment for margate it will bring
jobs um and uh overall
i'm for it so uh yes i will be
supporting this application thank you
thank you very much councillor curry
thank you chair um yeah i agree with
councillor zeki i believe
um this development would be a real
boost to the area
um and the club obviously however with
regard to the loss of
any open space or playing field i wonder
if ian could
tell us if any financial contributions
towards existing
community playing fields have
been included i know sport england did
mention this
as well um yeah thank you
thank you very ian can you um
yeah so that there isn't hasn't been um
anything secured through this planning
application and again this is about
um when a planning obligation is is
reasonable
um and also necessary to make the
development acceptable
and the important point here is about
the what is considered by officers to be
a quite realistic fallback which is that
the playing pitch you know the
car park could be extended tomorrow
under the previous consent
and the playing pitch would be lost and
that has to carry weight in the
determination of this application
uh you know i i don't i don't have in
front of me any any of the potential
arrangements that the market football
club do in terms of community and usage
of of pitches
um i'd imagine there is something there
but in terms of the consideration of
whether or not we should seek a
contribution towards
other community facilities as a result
of this development
it's not considered that actually would
make the development acceptable
that that obligation would be necessary
to make the development acceptable
given the full back position and ability
over the previous
um 14 years to to basically
um you know lose that section of of the
park through the fact that permission
has already been granted
okay thanks ian thank you and um
i think as i touched on on monday when i
had a
meeting with mr livingston um having a
look up
at tivoli wreckers i think we've always
known it uh
obviously it was the arlathanic tree
initiative though to put these
trees which you know in a few years time
are going to look good but there is
still room
for shall we say the portable
football pitch uh that's been mentioned
there where they go
you know in the the lesser that was read
out uh
the goals used to be brought out but
there is room
um possibly they might have to move just
a little bit but there is room up there
so
okay members um i can't see any other
members wish to speak um so i'm going to
put this to you once again i move that
the officer's recommendation is adopted
and as you've heard that is
to defer approval for approval but
deferring delicate
um i'm going to call out your names uh
once again
um it's like being at school uh
council coleman cook or
council alban's not here he should be
out walking cliftonville
uh councillor bateford for
hurry for councilman
against councillor heart for jet
councillor keane four
councilor paul moore four chair
council brazewski poor
councillor scott
having sat through this application a
long time ago and seen it refused it's
about time it's
it's a long time coming for the i am
supporting the absolute application
thank you councillor wright i'll go
along with that as well
so that is uh carried
uh thank you very much james for doing
that thank you member
um uh see you know hopefully all goes
ahead
uh okay um moving on now to
um that item for
f h percy avenue and i believe
uh monster organs
if he's been notified i think katie's
just giving him a call now
thank you james i'll just wait to
get councillorman back in
if council robin is there
he is thank you councilwoman
no doubt you will cliff tops um
right uh gender item four f eight
personal avenue
i will ask suki once again to read out a
statement from the public please
thank you sir this is a statement in
favor from mr hume who's the agent
good evening members my name is aleister
hume of hume planning consultancy and i
am speaking in support of this
application at 8 percy avenue
the proposals are for the redevelopment
of a vacant storage premises to create
five apartments
comprising a mixture of two and three
bed units i believe it is generally
accepted that the current building
which is to be converted and extended is
of a poor design
and makes no positive contribution to
the street scene
the proposal i believe will greatly
improve the look of the building
whilst making more efficient use of a
brownfield site within the settlement
confines
where development is both supported and
encouraged by local and national
planning policy
it is also relevant that following a
reduction in scale and depth of the
extensions which were negotiated during
the course of the application by the
case officer
the living conditions of adjoining
occupiers will also be safeguarded
acceptably
throughout the course of this
application the applicant has worked
with the case officer to take account of
their feedback and the comments of
neighbours
which has resulted in significant
amendments to the proposals including
a reduction in the number of dwellings
proposed from six to five units
a reduction in the overall massing and
extent of the proposed roof space
the inclusion of outdoor amenity space
for the units
and the provision of a five-car parking
spaces
one per unit following the above
amendments kcc highways and
environmental health have both
confirmed that they raised no objections
to the scheme
and broadstairs town council have not
raised objection to the application in
their latest responses
furthermore there were no neighbor
comments received on the latest round of
amended plans
in summary the proposal will replace the
existing unattractive building and will
prove
improve the appearance of the street
scene the principle of development is
supported by the development plan
and nppf the proposal is supported by
the case officer
and no objections have been raised by
the statutory councils and
the development will be constructed to a
high standard of energy and water
efficiency
to be secured by conditions 12 and 13
and will also introduce landscaping at
the site
on this basis it is respectfully
requested that members grant permission
for this application
in line with the office's recommendation
thank you sir
thank you very much suki um i will ask
councillor
bob bayfoot uh to speak as wall
councillor
thank you chairman uh evening members um
yes as was stated the original
application was for six flats there was
widespread objection
to that proposal and it was subsequently
reduced to five flats
but i believe that even with this
concession it's still a great
over development of the site and there
are still
local feeling against it and on the site
presently as
has been said is a single story flat
roof building
that's actually being replaced by a very
large three-story building
of what i think is poor design to me
it looks as though the main in fact
maybe the only driver here
is to maximize the return from the
development and little consideration has
been taken for its position in the
the neighborhood i believe the site is
suitable for something considerably
smaller
which could be more attractive and might
actually enhance the street scene
there's little or no landscaping there
is
parking provision for just five vehicles
which i think is inadequate
there could be two vehicles per flat and
there will be visitors
this will lead to parking on the road
near a junction which is very congested
on busy summer days
i also believe that there is some issue
about the validity of the five
parking spaces shown on the plan so if
it is for approval i hope officers will
actually check that out because there's
been some suggestion that
um you know the uh the applicant can't
provide those or isn't in position
to guarantee those five spaces um
members uh if you share my concerns i
hope you refuse this application
thank you uh thank you councillor
bayford um
uh i speak i would pass over to ian i
believe once again
no it's annabelle chair i bake a pardon
ian
um go to annabelle for her report please
thank you chad just share the screen
excuse me hopefully members can now see
the screen
okay we have the application site
outlined in red
and percy avenue to the left-hand side
of the slide
and we have a series of some aerial
photographs that may
help inform members about the site and
its relationship with surrounding
development
so this is the site here this
rectangular site we have gray friars
caught to the bottom of the slide here
and this is looking from king's sorry
from george hill road so this is king's
gate
sorry greyfriar has caught which is a
block of flats
the application site here and this is an
access road with some garages and
various
um parking spaces there
this is looking from kingsgate avenue so
the application site is here
there are houses along king's gate
avenue and this again is gray flyers
cult this is looking up at the site from
percy avenue so
this is numbers 12 and 10 um percy
avenue and number eight
is behind it here and that's the access
road we've looked at
and this is actually um looking at the
site
this is percy avenue here numbers 12 and
10
and number eight here and again this is
gray for eyes court
so just looking at some actual
photographs of the site
this is the number eight percy avenue
and this is numbers 10 and 12 percy
avenue
and this is number 10 and the edge of
number 12 on the left hand side of the
slide
and this is number eight and it can be
seen that it projects
some distance in front of number 10
and this is the access road here and
this is actually
grey friar's caught again as you can see
it's a lot
well a free small blocker flats this is
the side of number eight and this is the
access road
but where some car parking will be
provided to serve the flats
and you can see some distant car parking
there
and some garages as you go further down
this is again coming further down to on
that access road so
as can say there are garages
this is actually the access to
the flat on top of number 10
so this is the access to number 10 a
which is the flat above it
this is number 10 a and number 12 to the
right hand
side and this bit flat roof you can see
on the left hand side is the application
site
this is the existing block plan so has
been seen this is the application site
it projects further forward and number
10 and number 12.
this is great why it's called and that's
the access road that we've seen the
photographs
of and this is the proposed
block plan as has been mentioned
by the statement we've just heard there
are now
five um dwellings or flats proposed
within the
application there are two areas of
landscaping proposed one to the
front here and one to the rear and the
blue
dotted areas are the five parking spaces
that being referred to
so there are one at the front one at the
rear
and three within the access road
so this is the front elevation as
existing and you can see number 10
there as well this is the proposed
extension
um so essentially the bill sorry the
front proposed front elevation not
extension
so you can see that it
is in fact um a two-story
development with some rooms within the
roof
so essentially two and a half story
rather than the three that
has potentially been referred to and you
can see on the
um plan here and some dotted lines
in blue and that's an approval a
previous approval on the site
um that was granted in 2005 so there is
planning history of
um approvals here already
so this is the rear renovation and that
case we looked at going up to the flat
up
number on the top of number 10 and again
this is the proposed rear elevation and
you can again see the dotted line
of the pre previous approval
and these are the side elevations as
existing
and this is a proposed side elevation
and this is south the other side the
self elevation as existing
and this is the proposed elevation
and as you can see there was the open
space
areas that have been proposed each flat
would either have
an area of open space at ground level or
be served by terraces
at various levels so each flat would
have some area of open space
so this is the existing ground floor
layout and as has been mentioned the
building is currently
um actually unoccupied and vacant
so this is the proposed ground floor so
this is the area of
private amenity space that would serve
actually flat one
and it would have a car parking space
here and would have its own entrance
here
there were a further two flats um
located on the ground floor
and a communal entrance that would serve
all all the other four flats that
are in the development
again there is a parking space to the
rear here
and an area of private amenity space
this is the first floor so you have a
further two flats here
again with roof terraces as we've seen
and you can see again here
how much further it projects from
forward of number 10.
and again this is the essentially it's
it's referred to as second floor on the
drawing but it essentially is the bit
we've seen where
the rooms would be set within the roof
and these um
rooms that you can see here actually are
part of the flats on the first floor so
they are essentially masonite flats
these two
so essentially to summarise
um the proposal would bring would create
five units of
residential accommodation and would
bring an empty unit back into use
and that is supported by the council's
planning policies
there are no issues um from officer's
point of view with the standard of
proposed accommodation it meets the
technic national technical standards
and would provide light and ventilation
and provide a good standard of
accommodation for future occupiers
there is no impact on neighbour amenity
or highway safety
or parking a contribution is required as
with all residential
development for
the sam to mitigate against additional
recreational pressure on the sba
and that would be secured via a
unilateral
undertaking so the recommendation to
members is to defer and delegate full
receipt of that
undertaking thank you chair uh thank you
very much
uh annabelle i move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair please second
i'll second that chair uh thank you very
much um
members um right uh
councillor keane look just a quick
question thank you
um and that is is there any bike storage
annabelle can you
yes chair can come back on that yes
there is there's a communal bike store
as you go into the sort of main entrance
for that serves the four flats
thank you uh thank you uh councillor
joel bayford
thank you chair um as a kingsgate
resident um
i i also believe that the development is
still too big
um i'm pleased it's come down from six
units but i think it needs to come down
further it'll be far preferable to see
something smaller with some landscaping
and a little bit of space um with gray
fires
caught at the top of the road i think
that there's a huge amount of bulk
at the top of percy avenue which is is a
a very congested area anyway
um it's very very difficult for parking
and i think this is going to cause all
kinds of problems
if it goes through um i i personally
cannot support this application i would
prefer to see something much smaller
thank you chair uh thank you councillor
bakeford councillor wright
thank you chairman um i must admit i
agree with jill
um i've also uh my heart is in percy
avenue i spent a lot of my childhood
there
um but i i just think it looks like it
just does not look right
it just it's overbearing on on the
property next door
it just doesn't fit in thank you i won't
be supporting this application i'm
afraid
okay thank you councillor right um
i do not see any other members
wish to speak um so
i'm going to put this to you members uh
the recommendation as you've heard is
uh for approval and defer and delegate
um once again if i can go through your
names
please um you know how it works
uh counts the common cook again
sorry councillor against
council sorry i'm sorry chair i was
against yes
thank you councillor coleman cook
councillor alban against
councillor joe bayfoot against
councillor curry against
councillor ghana he's off
he has uh left the meeting um councillor
heart
for councillor keane
against councillor paul moore
against councillor zesky
abstain council scott
abstainer answer right
against and i'm going to abstain on this
one
um i'm looking for
james that has been
lost
right so therefore i come back to
ian or annabelle i'll i'll come back if
that's okay sure
yes thank you ian um so um
we've heard from from council debate
from council right
from the committee with regards to
concerns about the the scale of the
government and the fact that
uh in the the development doesn't fit in
with the character
the area um primarily due to the actual
location
of the development itself and its
relationship with the buildings
surrounding it so um
in terms of proposing a motion
for um reviews of the application
uh i can summarize some of the comments
that
have been made then on that basis um and
it's that
basically by virtue of the design and
scale of the proposal
uh that it would result in um
a a obtrusive and congress form of
development
uh unrelated to its setting
um which on the basis that's been put
forward
um would result in significant harm to
the character and appearance
of the area uh the policy that's
relevant in this instance is the
standard policy
which is uh qdo2 which looks at design
which members will be familiar with
um so that would be um that would be my
recommendation if members were
wanting to um you know were looking to
refuse the application
and wanted to propose a motion thank you
chair
thank you ian um you've heard ian's
comments there
um any more debate on that or
go straight to yourselves
no um yeah would you like to read out
well well it would need it would need
someone to propose the motion
for that refusal so i i can give the
advice but obviously
it would need a member
could i have a proposal please chairman
i'll propose
i'll propose exactly what mr livingston
has just said
i thought you might counsel robin could
i have a secret
right once again i do have to go through
these names as you're aware
um you've heard what's been said um
if you're for what's been said or
against or abstaining
uh councillor coleman cook for
councillorman four counts uh
joel bayford four councillor curry
four councillor heart
council hearts i'm there sorry trouble
with me buttons for
jeff thank you councilman four
councillor paul moore for chair
councillor zesky
council scott fortre
councillor right for a chair and i
for as well so that has been
carried so therefore we need
um a new motion put forward
or no no that's that's that's confirm
the refusal
that is confirmed you're happy with the
wording
thank you for that members um
okay that concludes um public speaking
for this meeting
i will call upon the clerk to read out
the remaining
planning application if a member wishes
to reserve the application
will they please call out as he reads
i will ask james please
thank you chair so the last item is um
agenda item 4b
chris park in chris park place
birchington
now does anybody does anybody wish to
speak
nope okay on that case
i would like uh um a proposal please
to move that their application that be
determined in accordance with the
officer's recommendation
could the vice chair please second
or second nature uh thank you council
coleman
uh put i'll get your name right uh sorry
about that uh
unless anybody uh objects to that
proposal i will take it that
it is agreed
yep thank you very much
right the last item on tonight's um
meeting or called upon mr livingston to
introduce
this report please ian
uh thank you chair i will just um
quickly present my screen
so it's scanning down to
the item there we go um
so this is an agenda item um it's
previously been considered by
members it's an application at
helen's poplar road broadstairs it was
before members december 2019 uh
january 2020 um supposed to be four
times
um for chinese to the store and and
flat um it came back and forth because
there was some discussion
about um the relationship between
the car parking here and the insertion
of a window that you may recall
here for the conversion of this store
room at the moment that's in this area
in the building
to a studio flat members resolved to
grant the application
um for approval subject to
the receipt of a unilateral undertaking
securing the sam's
contribution and that caveat is always
put on
that it occurs within six months well we
didn't receive
the unilateral undertaking within six
months and we've only received that in
in february this year
and so therefore we've reported back to
members
which is the requirement to um
to reaffirm the approval uh that's the
recommendation for officers because now
that the issue has been resolved with
regards to the intellectual undertaking
there'll be no changes to the proposal
and as the report outlines
it was originally considered against the
draft local plan policies
and so there isn't any change even
though the local plan was adopted in
july last year
it hasn't changed anything substantively
to come to a different determination
to approve subject to the safeguarding
conditions outlined
its annex one of the report and that's
the recommendation to members
thank you chair uh thank you and i think
uh those who are on the committee will
remember
um i was speaking about this on a couple
of occasions
um i moved the officers recommendation
is adopted
could the vice chair please second
second nurture
uh now members do you wish to debate
this
i have no names on my screen
um so i will have to ask you again
to agree or against or abstain
for the last time tonight sir so i start
with councillor coleman cook
for alban
before
four curry four
council of heart four chet
councillor keane four councillor paul
moore
four chair councillor pesky four
council scott porter councillor right
for chip and myself i'm for it
and that has been carried thank you for
that james so quick
members that concludes tonight's
uh planning meeting at
20 1938